est-ce que vous ne vous êtes pas
réveillé un peu tard sur ces questions
de sécurité j'en veux pour preuve les
chiffres qui viennent de votre propre
ministère les hausses de la violence des
atteintes aux personnes homicide en
hausse coups et blessures volontaires en
très nette hausse j'ai regardé votre
logo je pensais qu'on était sur ses news
mais en fait on est bien sur bs je vois
pas le rapport ne dit pas non plus et ce
soit aléatoire mais parce que vous ne
dites pas mais jamais on n'a pas la main
à l'occident blessés par les manières en
l'occurrence la matte ont permis aux
représentations elle est très rapide et
un peu populiste moi et c'est la
dyscalculie essayer de démontrer
l'inversé pas à calmer vos chiffres mais
calmez vous madame ça va bien se passer
aujourd'hui une baisse je trouve mon
sens ça va bien se passer il ya va bien
se passer comme ça je vous demande
pardon comme ça va bien dit que c'est
madame vous allez voir mais c'est à 30%
et à 30% de baisse sur les bien moi j'en
ai marre des discours populistes
à l'avancé s'est pas coupé de ouf mais
s'étend du coupé au moment où il va
donner l'explication encore exactement
le style en fait il y en a d'autres qui
vont pas bien vous avez assuré tout ce
qui va mieux exactement voilà c'est vrai
notre sais c'est mal coupés mais bon si
c'était bien coupée dans cette émission
ça serait
sympa
mais si non mais lui ce qui lui a pas
plu égérie d'armani en fait c'est
qu'elle donne qu'une partie du sur vous
vous dites non non il n'y a pas eu un
comportement irrespectueux dans un clip
en cas parce que pour moi effectivement
c'est sur le fond que ça pêche elle tord
les chiffres dès le début elle veut
piéger sur la sécurité et donc je trouve
qu'ils répondent sans sexisme sans être
j'ai dit ça parce que je savais vous
tombez dans le piège mais laïque
laissez moi finir pressé de finir celle
répond je trouve qu ils lui répondent
très bien il ne la prend pas de haut et
il essaye d'argumenter elle le vrai
envol je ne lui vois comme un supplice
les on va bien se passer ma ptite dame
j'ai entendu c'est là qu'est ce que je
vous ai dit en loge oui mais j'arrive
sur un vieux con mais personne ne prend
la parole quand je la donne pas c'est
insupportable dans cette émission donc
qu'est-ce que vous avez fini j'ai fini
oui
oui valérie bénaïm donc je réponds que
calmez-vous ma ptite dame circulez ya
rien à voir ça va aller ma ptite dame
donc toujours quand c'est une femme
c'est parce que c'est une hystérique que
en gros grosso modo ma petite dame je
vais vous expliquer la vie c'est madame
ça change tout
si un matin redis encore mal avec
quelqu'un mais j'entends bien mais ça va
bien se passer et calmez vous ça veut
dire qu'une femme en gros je vais
t'expliquer quatela vie mais et et ont
envoyé du sexisme note donc un bon
pensaient réellement qu'ils allaient
dire qu'il aurait dire même si leur
baisse dans votre oreille réellement
qu'il aurait dit à jean jacques et moi
j'ai adoré la police de palerme calèche
à dos j'adorais moi j'adorais j'ai adoré
le dira si l'audience
est au dessus ça n'a rien à voir non
monsieur je vous jure il aurait dit
qu'il aurait dit exactement la même
chose juste moi qui ai adoré pauline de
malherbe j'ai trouvé et non mais elle
était très drôle quand elle a cessé
comment
vous avez vu ses yeux mais un coup de
pression quoi oui moi j'ai bien aimé
parce que à la réglisse à bien se passer
madame comme dit on a le droit de dire
encore ça va bien se passer madame sauf
que moi c'est la première fois que j'ai
regardé le regard d'un pôle image m
c'est pas c'est pas trop mon truc un peu
le malheur c'est vraiment une amie elle
m'a fermé mon claque mon cas la paix
mais alors direct parce qu'ensuite tu
vois bien que jarno m'endormant il
redescend d'un étage et les gentils
après parce qu'elle dit comment ça a
commencé à lui fait voir que c'est pas
parce que il a montré l'autorité qu'elle
n'a pas elle non plus aussi de
l'autorité mois pour moi c'est une
contre une conversation normale
il y avait des 110 débattent et elle a
bien moins bien sorti les muscles à
montrer des monstres c'est du mépris
pour tout le monde dans l'ordre du jour
tourisme éventuellement je suis enfin
voilà j'en ai j'en sais rien mais dès le
début il commence en disant tiens on
n'est pas sûr chez new c'est populiste
c'était en gros ça c'était un trou
devrait si elle fait son métier depuis
quand les journalistes arrivent en
disant ah ben bravo là mais ça veut dire
quoi alors ça veut dire que sur bfm on
est complaisant avec le gouvernement ça
veut dire ça c'est ce que ça veut dire
catastrophiques l'avenir donc je vais
sur bfm parce que je vais tranquille je
ne suis pas d'accord laurent fontaine ça
c'est l'apothéose était
là dessus au dessus deux choses 1
évidemment il ya une différence selon
darmanin entre ces news et bfm
clairement seignosse et un peu plus ce
foxnews à l'américaine tout c'est un peu
un peu plus il ya plein d'émissions de
ce métier mais ça dépend c'est une
trahison réalisé bfm et un peu plus est
il ya plus de débat sur ces nuls et
surtout ce qu'on voit c'est complicité
entre darmanin et et et pauline valère
parce que quand tu voi intel ou qu'elle
a fait de balkany à trois jours ou
carrément ils ont laissé passer à
l'antenne avant de
vous dire par beaucoup d'argent il dit
ba 5 millions 10 millions 15 millions
claire gênée elle fait bon tu veux
connaître la haye le tutoie quoi et lui
tu veux qu'on arrête et ils l'ont
laissée ils l'ont enlevée au replay
regardez le sur les réseaux ça c'est
étonnant donc c'est clair apolline
scénariste politique de connivence et
connaissance d'un homme politique il la
sent qu'elle aime bien donc c'est normal
que vous avez mais elle avait des gens
que vous aimez bien il ya des gens avec
outre être plus honnête je vois pas en
quoi il a été respectueux
il a raison il faut être écoutés a fait
trois fois que tu retournes à ta
campagne
[Applaudissements]
chaque monde
avait compris quand on veut réparer mais
si c'est en fonction de ces
oui on s'est longtemps je trouve que
c'est n'ont fait que ces noms belges
tant qu'il n'ya pas s'arrêter
là mais en revanche c'est la tranquille
merci tu as là qu'il l'a mérité dans le
jeu trouve excusez moi qui l ai quand
même un peu de participer on sent
qu'elle est pas pourquoi qu'elle est pas
fan de quoi
non mais non ils vous êtes fous alors
ses lames étaient complaisantes on
l'aurait dit ah vous avez vu bfm non
entrés tous les ans au gouvernement
braquer et se braquer comme genre que ce
stade il a que je t'aime bien non
selon moi cette configuration veut que
ça se fight donc quand ces deux hommes
qui se fight est ce qu on dit que c'est
six mois ces fouilles c'est vrai que
bourdin ya eu plein des changes on a vu
des choses assez choquant en jeu deux
heures mais je vois pas pourquoi entre
un homme et les autres choses encore j'y
vois pas du sexisme moi je trouve c'est
le thème de l'émission mayroy change à
la raison mais les accusations de
sexiste pardon restent sont ridicules ça
veut dire quoi que parce que c'est une
femme on peut rien lui dire c'est
n'importe quoi il lui a jamais manqué de
respect il n'a pas insulté moi je pense
qu'elle a voulu mener comme ça ces boues
consommant unitaire du très musclé elle
est tombée sur un interlocuteur qui a du
répondant et elle est normal aussi elle
avait du mal à
te rappelle que bourdon et puis là elle
ne remplace un peu plus c'était la
guerre entre haubourdin réel bon alors à
août bâle a eu besoin de marquer un peu
sont très bonnes fait pas des audiences
absolument incroyable mais ça va venir
savons nous les audiences c'est comme
mon zizi ça montre tout le temps
ça vont un jour
une seconde sur la section contre ces
news parce que ça c'est pas bien c'est
assez d'accord il faut défendre le
travail d'une rédaction avec des débats
contradictoires des débats très virulent
mais je trouve que là il en bourse à la
fin alors je croyais qu'on était je
croyais qu'on était sur ces annonces
avaient droit
ça dans son esprit c'est clair ça veut
dire je suis venu là parce qu'on allait
bien d'autres étaient donc déjà ça va
pas et ensuite dire que c'est mieux ah
oui un traitement partial de l'info ça
c'est pas dynamique irradie ne va pas eu
alors moi d'abord j'ai trouvé que
c'était une master class d'apolline de
malherbe je trouvais exceptionnel
ensuite je trouve que dit rien
catastrophique ils et elles désiraient
en rock et il est méprisant il est
condescendant très haut parce que vous
adorez apolline aussi bout moi je la
connais pas mais je la trouve et je les
vends moins bonne avec balkany pour le
coup pas là donc je suis j'ai une sorte
d'honnêteté intellectuelle que là je la
trouve une pluie parfois je la trouve
moins bonne donc là j'ai trouvé
excellente lui il vient pas en tant que
ministre il y en a un en tant que futur
d'autres représentants de macron futur
candidat donc en fait en gros il veut
montrer bfm ce sera du côté de macron et
senio ce sera du côté l'extrême droite
donc c'est nullissime il est nul sur les
chiffres et pardon moi ça va bien se
passer madame là et bien je trouve ça
horrible merci gérald dahan mais d'une
violence ça va bien ça il aura que il
aurait dû y alors vous n'aurez pas dit
il aurait pas dit
ce gars disent il ya des limites inspire
moi vraiment une connotation sexuelle
qui est même du genre laisse-toi faire
ça
alors alors on l'a vu j'ai vu des gens
penser comme géraldine sur les réseaux
d'eau les buvettes c'est bon tu veux pas
je n'ai vu sa tête après après ma chance
qu'il aurait dit exactement la même
chose à jean jacques bourdin ou à un
autre interviewer c'est sûr et certain
c'est une expression après bon bah oui
67%
et non 1 32%